bonjour nicolas prise bonjour merci de
me recevoir
vous êtes le président de la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives êtes
de passage chez nous notamment à
l'occasion du 25e anniversaire du cifan
c'est le centre interministériel de
formation anti drogue nicolas prise
cette lutte contre les drogues qui
contre les conduites addictives c'est un
peu l'histoire sans fin on a envie de
vous demander pourquoi sortes de moyens
faute de méthode l'évolution très rapide
des contextes oui c'est une histoire
sans fin qui n'est certainement pas
terminé encore aujourd'hui mais c'est
l'objet de ma visite ici il faut se
mobiliser tous encore et toujours contre
l'ensemble de ces conduites addictives
la 1000 des cas c'est une petite
administration qui est placée au premier
auprès du premier ministre elle
rassemble dans l'équipe de 30 personnes
que je dirige aujourd'hui des gens qui
viennent d'horizons très différents des
professionnels qui sont des médecins des
personnes du secteur social des
magistrats des policiers des gendarmes
toutes ces personnes essaient de trouver
justement de nouvelles solutions d'
impulser de nouvelles actions et mieux
coordonner l'action de l'état auprès de
l'ensemble de leurs partenaires
ministériel pour précisément essayer de
travailler sur ce qui va faire que cette
question des drogues va être un peu plus
attaquer un peu plus vulnérables et dans
vos bureaux en mai sur le même pied les
trafics de stupéfiants l'alcool la
cigarette ou encore même l'addiction aux
jeux
oui absolument et tout ça c'est parce
que on a des données scientifiques qui
nous prouve que les mécanismes cérébraux
les neurosciences nous montre ça quand
on consomme un certain nombre de
produits ont fait appel à ce qu'on
appelle un circuit de la récompense un
intérêt à l'intérieur du cerveau et ça
entraîne une forme de satisfaction qui
fait qu'on ne peut plus s'en passer et
c'est un peu la même chose
qu'il s'agisse de substances telles que
le tabac l'alcool ou les drogues de
certaines addictions sont substance donc
il ya au départ des grands même en étant
t on est tenté de faire une sorte de
classification la drogue pure dur style
cocaïne crack plus dangereuses que
l'alcool l'alcool plus dangereuses que
les jeux alors je vais vous donner pour
qu'on fasse cette classification des
données objectives à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de la république française
73 mille morts par an dus au tabac
cinquante mille liés à l'alcool 1600
liés aux drogues illicites
évidemment on n'a pas sur la question du
jeu vraisemblablement autant de morts
simplement aujourd'hui vous n'avez qu'à
interroger des parents d'adolescents qui
s'interroge quand même sur le repli sur
soi d'un certain nombre de jeunes qui
avec leur écran avec les jeux en ligne
avec les réseaux sociaux sont dans une
bulle qui fait que la relation sociale
devient vérité s'appauvrit au fur et à
mesure et ça c'est quand même pas très
bon pour nos enfants on va quand même
rappeler ce chiffre qui émane de la
préfecture pour 2016
à cause de l'alcool un accident de
voiture
l'alcool est à l'origine d'un accident
de voiture sur deux en martinique les
spécifités de la martinique
on boit beaucoup on fume moins seul en
france mais en termes d'un consommation
de drogue on parle de cannabis et de
crack ça vous interpelle vous oui je
crois qu'il faut être vigilant sur tous
les produits
je me félicite mois de ce conte
martinique
on ne fume moins de tabac qu'ailleurs il
faut rester très vigilant sur ces
questions parce que je rappeler les
chiffres c'est le produit le plus
meurtrier qu'il faut être très vigilant
là dessus
l'alcool est un véritable problème qui
se banalise aujourd'hui encore une fois
à l'échelle de l'ensemble du territoire
mais singulièrement à la martinique avec
des consommations chez les jeunes qui
sont de plus en plus fréquentes sous
forme ce qu'on appelle alcoolisation
ponctuelle importante le fameux binge
drinking on boit beaucoup d'un seul coup
pour arriver à des états second alors
évidemment quand on prend sa voiture
derrière c'est la catastrophe
évidemment ça entraîne des phénomènes de
violence entre personnes des violences à
vous parlait déjà d'adultes mais il ya
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de récits de
témoignages qui évoque des collégiens
qui se retrouve déjà en état d'ébriété
dans l'interface entre midi et deux tout
simplement
absolument donc il faut avoir des règles
il faut avoir un disque les règles ne
suffisent pas toujours il faut mieux les
appliquer notamment sur la question de
la vente d'alcool aux mines
qui est théoriquement interdite mais qui
est assez mal respectée sur l'ensemble
du territoire encore une fois ce qu'il
faut c'est avoir un discours public et
un discours partagé avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes qu'ils soient très
claires sur ces dangers là je reprends
le deuxième exemple que vous citiez tout
à l'heure le cannabis on sait très bien
pendant des années cette substance a été
considéré comme un vrai faux problème
c'est cool c est relativement cool bon
on a d'abord parlé enfume voilà way
aujourd'hui les études scientifiques je
reviens toujours à ça mais nous montre
bien que c'est un produit
particulièrement dangereux si on le
consomme tôt et jeunes dangereux parce
que ça donne des troubles de la mémoire
ça donne des troubles de l'attention et
qu'est ce que ça donne quand on a à 15
ans 16 ans des troubles de la mémoire et
de l'attention ça donne un parcours
scolaire qui s'effondre
l'inserm a montré ça avec une
publication très intéressante du mois de
mai dernier que le parcours scolaire des
jeunes qui fument précocément du
cannabis est un parcours qu'ils aient
toutes choses égales par ailleurs quelle
que soit votre milieu d'origine les
facilités que vous pouvez avoir ou les
difficultés que vous pouvez rencontrer
c'est un parcours qui est moins bon que
les à vous savez ce que vous disent des
consommateurs de cannabis de de
marijuana de juin comme andy comme on
dit tout simplement
mais arrêtez de nous emmerder avec la
consommation du de cette herbe
il ya beaucoup plus dangereux que
l'alcool mettez les moyens sur l'alcool
qui tuent régulièrement
il faut mettre les moyens surtout il
faut pas opposer les choses il faut pas
opposer les produits parce que je vous
le disais tout à l'heure c'est les mêmes
mécanismes au fond c'est les mécanismes
qui font qu'un 1
un jeune j'allais presque dire un enfant
fini par avoir besoin de se mettre dans
des états second c'est pas tout à fait
le moment en tout cas dans des était un
peu particulier pour supporter son
existence et se projeter dans l'avenir
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un
entrée dans dans les écoles dans le
système de l'éducation nationale pour
appeler pour déjà informé c'est très
très jeunes sur les risques de la
consommation de drogues mais ces jeunes
on va leur demander de faire ici par
exemple attention à l'accueil
touristique de faire attention à la
planète qu'il faut protéger
est ce que c'est le rôle de l'école
devenir le réceptacle de tous qu'on
n'arrive pas acculé par ailleurs
alors il ya plusieurs choses qu'on peut
essayer de faire et c'est le rôle de la
1000 des cas d'élaborer le prochain plan
gouvernemental sur le sujet qui devrait
voir le jour dans le premier semestre
2018 je reviendrai sur l'école dans un
instant mais je rappelais premièrement
avoir un discours public est partagé qui
soit claire sur les risques et les
dangers des différents produits sans
banalisation mais également sans
dramatisation excessive
les expérimentations on sait quel
surviendront de toute façon chez un
certain nombre d'adolescents la question
c'est comment on évite que s'installent
des consommations puis que s'installe
les addictions ça c'est la première
oeuvre
le premier sujet le deuxième sujet ce
sont les questions j'en parlais tout à
l'heure à propos de l'alcool mais c'est
vrai aussi pour le tabac d'accessibilité
aux produits comment est ce qu'on peut
faire respecter le fait que s'il ya des
interdits de vente qui ne sont pas
toujours totalement respectée comment
est ce qu'on peut faire en sorte
aujourd'hui d'avoir des politiques assez
sérieuse pour limiter la publicité et la
publicité qu'on tournait parfois de ces
produits-là par le biais notamment de
ceux qu'on trouve en ligne ou des
sollicitations diverses et variées et
puis vous avez raison il ya l'école
alors l'école c'est un sujet compliqué
ouais d'abord parce que effectivement je
crois profondément qu'il faut agir très
tôt on a souvent eu des politiques de
prévention qui se sont adressés aux
jeunes entre guillemets les jeunes c'est
quoi ça commence quand et c'est souvent
les difficultés de vie quand vous
commencez à informer a essayé de
travailler sur ces sur ces jeunes
adolescents à 14 15 16 ans les choses
sont déjà installés il aurait aimé
devenir beaucoup plus tôt faut
intervenir plus tôt alors est ce qu'il
faut faire il faut dire par exemple à
ces très jeunes qu'ils peuvent avoir
confiance en eux mêmes parce qu'ils
auront un projet un but
il réforme sur les réalités de la vie
alors revenons-en encore une fois des
résultats scientifiquement démontré
aujourd'hui on sait à peu près ce qu'il
faudrait faire
c'est effectivement certainement pas la
multiplication d'interventions
informatif ponctuelles sur tous les
sujets de société que vous avez l'alcool
tue de boire a pas fait attention à
l'environnement fait attendre ok ça on
sait que ça marche très moyennement et
en plus en général dans le parcours
scolaire c'est un peu désordonné ça
arrive au gré de la disponibilité des
intervenants et c'est ce qui est
important c'est effectivement
dès le primaire en encadrant aussi et en
associant les familles de pouvoir faire
que l'école bienveillante arrive à
donner un peu plus confiance je dis un
peu plus haut on créera pas des miracles
mais c'est simplement faire en sorte
qu'un gamin se sentent aujourd'hui un
petit peu plus sûr de lui qu'il sache
quand est-ce qu'il doit demander et
quand comment il peut demander un
soutien à l'adulte une information qu'on
se sente un peu mieux que ses enfants se
sentent un peu mieux c'est vraiment une
question de bien-être et de
bienveillance aujourd'hui qui avec
l'éducation nationale on essaie de
développer au travers de programmes
allant pardon le mot est un peu
compliqué de renforcement des
compétences psychosociales mais ça veut
bien dire ce que ça veut dire c'est que
je suis compétent pour être bien moi
même avec les autres un beau très rapide
sur l'aéroport de las de aimé césaire à
fort de france
la martinique est sur le lieu du trafic
de drogue du sud vers le nord est avec
cet accord international c'est aussi un
lieu de passage vers l'europe
est-ce qu'il faut sanctuariser davantage
terre ou pas pour qu'il n'y ait pas
autant d'annonce de saisie détermination
mais c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
s'il ya des annonces de saisie et
d'interpellations est en réalité parce
qu'on sait que lorsque et abrite si on
sait que les trois autres sont passés
alors c'est effectivement un sujet très
compliqué d'arriver à faire en sorte que
tous les trafiquants puisse être le cas
échéant interpellé et la marchandise
saisie
cela dit moi je range rend vraiment
hommage et s'est logée au sigma visite
ce matin je j'ai une réunion justement
sur la lutte contre le trafic à
l'ensemble des forces qui travaillent
sur ce sujet on verra justement s'il ya
moyen des moyens de faire mieux
c'est le maritime c'est évidemment
l'aéroportuaire et c'est d'une manière
générale également tout le trafic
un terril entre dans la région merci
nicolas piste d'avoir été avec nous on
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la mission interministérielle de lutte
contre les drogues et les conduites
addictives en martinique jusqu'à
vendredi merci bonne journée
[Musique]